ha I love Thanksgiving but there's one
thing that gets me what the turkey it
always makes me sleepy okay what I'm
sorry but did you just blame your post
Thanksgiving sleepiness on the turkey
yeah turkey has a bunch of tryptophan in
it the stuff that makes you super sleepy
what I'm not so sure about that
I mean let's talk about this is it
really the turkey that makes you so
tired on Thanksgiving true or false
my money's on true well okay you're
right that Turkey has tryptophan in it
but so do a lot of high-protein foods
did you know for example that cheese
actually has more tryptophan than turkey
tryptophan is a precursor to serotonin
that's the neurotransmitter that gives
you happy feelings right the chemical
that's released in the brain if you have
sex or do drugs
yeah it's responsible for the warm and
fuzzy feels but also it gets converted
into melatonin which is the chemical
that makes you sleepy ah so it does make
you sleepy
well yeah it can but no more than other
protein rich foods though the reason why
it makes you extra sleepy on
Thanksgiving is because you eat that
turkey with a whole bunch of carbs all
those carbs speed up the process of
converting that tryptophan into
melatonin so you get sleepy faster
thanks to the carbs plus you've just
eaten a crazy amount of food right so
your body is slowing down to try and
digest it all Oh God
not to mention all of the wine I mean
it's really just a perfect storm for the
melatonin factories in your brain to
just kind of go wild and flood your
system with sleepiness oh I can't just
blame it on the turkey no girl you can't
just blame it on the turkey anymore it's
the whole shebang I'm sorry it's a food
myth it's false